all right we have this on our website
you got to see this all right prepare
yourself because we are taking you
inside of a tornado does it get more
intense than this right here look at
this and look at the center of your
screen you see that red pickup truck
spinning around whoever's driving that
got swept up by the wind but eventually
landed back on all four wheels right
there when a tornado does that to you do
what this person did simply drive away
go to the hospital and go buy a lotto
ticket
because
he's surviving a lucky fella is that
right because i do know how to drive on
ice i know how to drive in snow but i
never thought of that in terms if so in
a tornado
you get out of your car no but when
you're already in it when you're already
in it yeah we tell you this you put your
seat belt on and you put your head down
because you have shards of glass coming
so you got to protect your face
and what happens is that can pick up
that car and you're in it and drop you
200 feet down you're not going to
survive and we've seen that happen
before good so that guy
called me glad he's okay
he needs to come to vegas next seriously
ted that's why i said buckle up at the
end of the story
buckle up
always wear the seat belt right wow that
guy lucky all right back here at home of
course not as much intense weather here
we've got the winds yes
but those winds will die down and then
we got fantastic weather for a few days
and if you want some heat you're going
to get it 75 degrees our official high
for the day today after 71 yesterday 53
your morning start not bad a couple
degrees above normal and 91 the record
on the state in 2004 and we're going to
reach those 90s that's in the eight day
76 for sky canyon right now and same for
you at providence in centennial hills 75
spring valley same for north las vegas
and downtown 76 whitney ranch and green
valley 75 henderson 73 in the southern
highlands we're at 75 degrees i should
say right around inspirada and cadence
there 73 for anthem 79 currently for
prop double sevens for you mesquite 79
also for laughlin point is right now
outside very pleasant very comfortable
and that will be the case tomorrow
before we start to really wrap things up
i want to go back to the severe storms
right now that we're seeing now in the
deep south not texas but the deep south
here and the storm we're watching is
right here right around the big easy
moving into mississippi and what we look
for is what we call a hook echo on the
radar right kind of curves and we did
see a bit of it here but the latest
latest
image here does show that hook echo now
starting to decrease so yeah tornado
warning still in that spot there slidell
louisiana into western portions of
mississippi as that remains in effect as
those storms are severe enough to spawn
tornadoes it's going to be a rough night
tonight for those areas in the deep
south back here at home the breezy winds
now decreasing and tonight they'll
decrease even more although i still
think some of the northern and northeast
neighborhoods could still see some of
those north breezes but we get to
wednesday and thursday and look at that
things calm down things great all the
way through friday as far as your winds
go but get ready for the roller coaster
temperatures because look at that we go
up to the 90s and then back down to the
70s all in that eight day forecast
tonight 52 degrees overnight clear and
cool look for north breezes tomorrow 76
a beautiful day with lighter winds for
tomorrow here's your eight day forecast
so we will break some records we think
on friday and saturday and come close to
the record on sunday and then don't
worry we get right back to the cooler
more seasonal temperatures early on next
week with a chance for showers the
question is who's going to heat their
pool
on friday
and saturday
well you don't need to heat it you can
jump you can jump in anyways well i do
the
solar yeah yeah i go and so it kind of i
let the sun
let the sun do its thing here in las
vegas and heat it up for it well hey
things are heating up for the raiders
because they signed a huge star and we
got to meet him today yeah and
everybody's excited about this guy they
can't wait for otas and even these camps
to get this going surrounding the
raiders now with devonta